all right so we got two major Vlog
updates the first major update is
exactly what Geo is doing right now
and you can tell
she is steam cleaning no and steamy
she's steaming and steaming because
she's mad that our new puppy just peed
on this beautiful carpet I'm not mad at
that what are you mad at you
closing it off and pretending like this
guy is
trained and not a three-month puppy
puppy left him
just can you say three month puppy as
angry as you can no no say it say three
month puppy angry no
because you know how cute that just saw
that you know better
oh someone said
so as mama said she is correct I'm wrong
when I left to go get a haircut I should
not have left Cooper by himself without
boarding up the living room but look at
this guy's face how can you board up the
living room when they look like this hey
Mia Mia and Cooper have been getting
along so well they're literally best
buds now
which is so CUNY so the story is
actually pretty crazy hey Cooper show
everyone a little kitty face first
Cooper
Cooper oh look at this face Cooper big
CUNY
oh you guys are the best
brother and sister
yeah so as you can see he's a little
three-month-old German Shepherd puppy we
think he's gonna be pretty big because
look how big his paws are his paws are
um Mia's size
and look at that
and he's only three months old
and they just play like that all day
so the story is pretty crazy
um as you guys know we've been saying it
for like a year now
that taika's been wanting to have
puppies right since we haven't had fun
meatloaf and briggy since in LA and then
since the pandemic hit and we moved to
Vegas and then we knew we're gonna get
another house we just knew that there
was too much movement to have dogs but
you guys know us we love dogs starting
with my German Shepherd when I was 15.
we had Tyson remember him if you guys
have been following us for a long long
long time we had Tyson patches patches
passed away that's when we got Fawn then
we had Tyson and and fun and then we had
briggy and then Tyson passed away and
then we had meatloaf and yes can I play
it here no because I'm talking to I'm
telling the story of how we got
Mr Cooper
a giant sandwich because that giant
sandwich is for them you crazy bones
hey how come you don't have a shirt on
hey don't whack them like that that's
not nice he's a baby okay where was I
okay right so um we haven't had a dog a
long time but you guys know we are a dog
family we love dogs and especially as
Taco gets older he realizes we don't
have dogs anymore and he wants to have a
puppy like a lot of kids do and so much
so that he even had a name picked out
already he was like I want two puppies
Mia and Cooper and we're like those are
the cuniest names ever
um we'll get a Mia and Cooper so we've
been on the lookout since we moved here
because we finally stable We're not
gonna move again and we kind of have a
routine in our life because that's the
main thing of bringing pets in your life
you don't want to have an unstable life
like pets need to be walk in the morning
walk that night things need to be
predictable for them to be healthy or
else they get stressed out from a
unstable life
so we've been on the lookout and um we
love West Side German Shepherd rescue go
check out the IG go check out the
website we've adopted fawn from there
um they specialize in German Shepherds
as long as it's like 25 German they'll
do whatever they can to like remove them
from high kill shelters and stuff like
that and I love German Shepherds so
that's what we got fawn from
and uh we saw Mia pop up and she's part
a German Shepherd part husky that's when
we got Mia
and since we got Mia it's been like six
months now I've been looking at their
Instagram
every single day because we need to get
Cooper
and for Cooper
um I wanted like a big like alpha male
like Tyson and meatloaf you know so I've
been waiting but the other thing is
since Titus so little we also want a
puppy because we don't want a situation
like meatloaf to happen where he comes
with a bunch of trauma like he's all
cute and and stuff with us we take him
to the dog park and because we don't
know what happened uh to him in his
upbringing and we haven't had a hand in
his upbring he just wants to kill every
single dog at the dog park so we don't
want anything like that you know we want
a dog that has zero trauma that we could
raise with taika and won't bite taika
most importantly
so I've been looking and uh just a few
days ago I saw Westside German Shepherd
rescue post a dog named Nate and oh he
is beautiful so they have their names
and then one should adopt the dog you
name them your names
um Nate was beautiful he look classic
German Shepherd you could tell how big
his paws are and even
um on the Instagram caption like Nate's
gonna be a big boy
so we immediately went there to go check
out Nate but then but then Nate and Mia
couldn't get along and we love Nate so
much mainly me because he was beautiful
and he just looked at his paws you're
like oh he's gonna be one of those big
ass German Shepherds that you see at the
dock bar like a hundred pounds I really
want to make it work
but it just wouldn't work and you can
you could tell his energy was too much
and even though he was a baby like he
was kind of like bullying Mia even
though he's smaller it's just like a lot
of energy and you could just see me like
not wanting to play with them and all
that and we spent 30 minutes trying all
different things uh correcting his
behavior
the West Side German Shepherd rescue
volunteer left just to see if he that
would change the dynamic we had taika
stop moving stand on the side which is
all he flies on the wall just change all
the different Dynamics to see how it
play out and me it just wasn't having
him so that guy was like hey you know
what
um we do have another puppy his name is
Jacker and we can see how he
uh interacts with Mia and at that time I
was like
ah okay I mean we'll try some anything
you know because I was I really had my
heart set on Nate but the mature
uh decision and the decision the better
decision for the overall families to
make sure the whole family Dynamic is
important you know like we love me and I
don't want Mia to like you know like not
get along like one of my favorite
Dynamics if you watch the old Vlogs is
fun and bringing like they would just
play with each other and their best buds
and having a great time and then
meatloaf just sitting in the corner like
just not wanting to deal with them at
all you know so I wanted a a fun and
bricky type of dynamic
so I was like well Nate's not gonna fit
that that Vision so he brings out Jagger
and instantly like they got along so
well they're playing already they're
having a good time and we're like oh
this is night and day difference and
Jagger which we now named uh Cooper has
the cutest eyes you can see the whites
behind his eyes and his eyes are these
light Browns look at these big brown
eyes super duper cute we bring them home
the whole car ride not a fuss
um let me just have a picture I'll show
you guys a picture but uh Cooper and Mia
were just laying on each other the
entire car ride like they were so CUNY
and literally like they're like this all
day next to each other doing their own
thing or either that or laying on each
other you know what's not CUNY what the
hole in my [__] carpet what hole
you'll see it
that is your Offspring we did we were so
CUNY weren't we and we came out here to
a grumpy old lady
bit a freaking hole he hasn't even been
here two days
look thank you thank you is that you did
you do that yeah
are you sure
he's trying to blame you don't let him
blame you are you sure it's not you
but it looks like the size of your mouth
that looks like the size of your mouth
oh no oh no no no no no no no no no
all right finally in a room I'm at
Tiger's room actually so I can share
some CUNY stuff with you this is them
in the whole car ride I'm like this is
the dynamic that we exactly wanted look
at that you see how cute that is
or just next to each other
and and it's very rare for dogs to just
get along like that but that's what I'm
saying the story is crazy because I'm
like this is
awesome they're either like side by side
touching like did I see them in the back
they're like sides always have to touch
they're always hanging out
this is both of them a mobra's lap
and then today
um let me see what the easy
today where's the pictures
let me see oops sorry it's fat finger
slipped and move fingers around
like this is them working with Mama just
in the room together
they're freaking the best there's one
more picture I wanted to show you
because this this picture truly shows
how much they like hanging out
so they have the whole living room okay
to hang out and they decide to just be
on each other
so yeah now we got a brand new addition
to our family his name is Cooper our Mia
and Cooper are complete
um and he is
a three-month-old I don't know because
that's the thing with the shelter I
don't know if he's gonna be that big
Alpha German Shepherd that I wanted but
he's so freaking CUNY I don't really
care
um and tomorrow we're actually gonna
drop them off at the exact same Training
Center that we dropped off Mia because
we had a really good experience there
like Mia knows how to sit place
um down walk Lee a leashless uh come to
us like she knows all these like super
dope commands so we want to make sure
that
uh Cooper is on the same page and the
younger you could send the puppies the
better because that's still an
imprinting phase but if you guys are
looking to get uh pet obedience training
even pet
um security training they have like
fully trained police dogs too go to Las
Vegas canine training
and uh mod Bear's gonna drop
um
Cooper off tomorrow and she may or may
not Vlog it but I wanted to share that
with you guys
so the other big life CUNY update is
we're making progress on our backyard
because check it out boom
look at that
this is the start of where things are
gonna visually change like crazy so the
whole aesthetic as you guys seen in the
past Vlog we're going for modern
Mediterranean which means there's lots
of whites and creams and beiges and
greens and um the pavers that we have
which are these like brick tile looking
things it's more like a darker maroon
tone so all of this is gonna get ripped
out and it's going to be replaced with
these super beautiful like cream
you can see Mia Mina what are you doing
in there you crazy lady
and poo poo but it's that color right
there let's see
right there
see that beautiful cream right there
porcelain
so this is gonna be
that's the color
um and in the sun like under direct sun
it looks almost white like when it's uh
like facing the sky
so
that's gonna cover this whole area which
is why they laid out that rope you see
that like
that uh you can't even see it on the
camera but you see this orange rope they
laid all that out so that
um it's mapped out and I'm not sure if I
showed you this part
but we put the water line tile in so
that's the tile where the water is going
to come up to
so it's already starting to slowly get
there and even that tile that we have on
the hot tub it's like this sparkly like
white cream Gray hot tub so everything
like if you look at it it's going to be
that like white tone
and it's going to span
this whole backyard
pretty much
Mia's colors is the mood board for our
backyard come here
where's your brother
here's a good shot of the porcelain it's
going to be called praia
Gray
and they're big big old slaps
so it's gonna look super nice and uh I
think the phase that they're in right
now is you see all that gravel right
there
that are laying out all the gravel so
that they can even it out because then
there's going to be Turf so you have to
make sure this whole thing is level and
I believe they're going to pile on a
bunch of dirt that way because we're
gonna create a little step up here a
little step action and what's super cool
about
um the step action and which is also why
I love our dude Ace who's the one
helping us design our backyard he
actually walked like all the perimeters
of our backyard and he wanted to like
like really take it in and see how we
can maximize it and so one of the things
that he noticed is from this section of
the backyard this is the attention of
detail he has from here he says you can
actually see the strip and I'm like oh
snaps
that's something that I didn't even
notice so he's like if we can see the
strip from your backyard we should set
something up so that's why he's going to
fill all this part up that we can have
like a little bonfire a little like
seating area so that we can enjoy the
strip from the backyard because people
paid big bucks to see it lit up at night
which is super cool but my favorite view
is for sure this one
from the backyard to be able to see the
mountains like that
is freaking insane
so cool so peaceful
look at all the red on those rocks
hello Cooper
nice of you to join us
look at Mia
I love that their colors are almost
opposite too like Mia's like almost all
white and gray and then Cooper is just
this like
looks like someone just colored them
with a sharpie
oh
are you gonna be a big German Shepherd
are you gonna stay that size
I hope you're a big fella
like your predecessors
like Tyson and meatloaf
this place is gonna be so fun
we're gonna have so many fun activities
over here like that's gonna be the turf
and it's all the porcelains over here
and then oh actually we're gonna put a
gym over there so we're gonna move the
gym out of our garage
because realize it's kind of cramped so
I actually have a ton of space right
here
so I was like we don't really use the
side yard so what we can do is build an
awning so we don't bake in the Sun and
then build the gym right there I think
that's like 15 feet Maybe
so we could build the gym right there
and then that way we can still watch
tiger play we have a pool
everything is slowly coming together
one thing I also want to give me a huge
prop sign this is how I know she's such
a good big sister
day one
when we brought
um Cooper home he came in he was thirsty
and the first thing he went was to drink
out of the same water bowl that meal is
drinking out of and Mia was not
territorial at all she just let him and
yeah and then it's super CUNY and then
now he's technically eating out of Mia's
dog bowl and Mia doesn't even care
it's a CUNY little family
so CUNY
yeah me is just letting him eat like a
good big sister because technically
Cooper's dog bowl is right here
but he wasn't hungry earlier so he made
him all his food
um through I think the doctor told us to
give him some moist food so we mixed the
moist food in with the uh
with the kibble
and he wasn't eating it but for some
reason
he likes
Mia's food
what is that most food the doctor told
us not the doctor I'm not talking about
the shelter told us to give him
that's how we made it we had to
mix it together yeah right here
Health growth formula for puppies so we
just took a big lump of that
and then mix it with the kibble
because I think he's still got little
baby teeth so we need him to be able to
like digest and eat a little bit
something soft a little bit something
hard and eventually wean them off of it
but they're the best that's them all day
two little best friends
so Mama did a really good job
and you can't even tell they peed mama
look at this
whoa that's crazy yeah it was bright ass
yellow that's one thing I know I'm
acting all grumpy and I'm doing it more
so as a bit because I think it's funny
but
um it's expected when you do get a brand
new puppy I know they look super cute
let's take this seizure medicine yeah um
I know it's super cute but I definitely
want to where's your phone
it's gonna keep going off yeah that's
one thing we have so
taika takes it's easier to medicine at 6
45 a.m 6 45 p.m and because we know as
life depends on it we have alarms
multiple alarms on multiple phones but
back to the puppy combo hold on look
less than
I want you guys to see how smart this
guy is come inside cooper cooper come
inside
come inside cooper cooper come come
come inside cooper cooper
come here Cooper
Cooper
come inside Cooper koopy does it oh no
okay never mind oh yeah he was he wasn't
even trying to come inside
um but yeah like less than 24 hours
um this guy learned how to come inside
and use a doggy door and he's freaking
smart because he's technically still a
baby he's only three months these are
pretty daunting and scary for a lot of
little pups because it's slam it hits
you in the face it makes this really
loud noise but back to the puppy
conversation
um if you do decide to get a puppy I'm
always gonna say rescue but if you
whatever if you do get the puppy
um just know that it's a lot of [__]
work so I was already expecting it
especially because we just had us but I
always want to call her phone she does
have fun and she's very fun she's very
chilly she's like fine and bring you put
together yeah
I was like
oh where to pot they're not potty
trained so they [__] everywhere
shouldn't pee they freaking bite
everything they bark at everything they
cry for everything they're absolutely
lost it's just expect a newborn [__]
baby in your house so it's a lot a lot a
lot a lot of work but then it's so worth
it because it's such a small sliver in
time honestly you're probably gonna
experience it for maybe like the first
handful of months
um and it and then like with every
passing month it becomes less and less
less and less and less they grow up so
quick huh they grow up so fast usually
make it on my face yeah
um so even with Tyson I remember like I
had him when he was two months and by
six months he was already like almost
almost five feet tall like that's how
fat like when he stood up he was already
here I hope we can get away from to get
that big like that's how fast he grew so
it was just like a blink in the eye so
it's like we have him for like this size
just for a little bit like once we let
us send him the training he's already
gonna come back like already like a head
bigger and
you know that's why I'm cherishing this
CUNY little moments look at that guy
yeah he's gone tomorrow Cooper coops he
knows his name too look at that
Cooper
smart guy
smoke
hi Mia
is he like that come inside Cooper come
Cooper come Cooper come here Cooper come
on Cooper come inside Cooper oh you sat
down no I don't even think he wants to
come inside
come inside cooper cooper
Cooper you want to come inside
no I don't think I think he likes being
outside
now he's chasing a leaf
CUNY girl you're the best big sister
ever oh General eyes closed you know
that yes yeah her eyes closed like yeah
right now her eyes are closed she's
enjoying it so much oh my God that's the
freaking mess look at the best clothes
my favorite girl okay so this [__]
complained about me leaving the dog by
himself look what this tell them the
truth
so taika wanted hot dogs for dinner so
I'm like all right fine I'll give you
hot dogs we never get it so I had
everything in the fridge or so I thought
I pulled out the bread
I just came back from the grocery store
yeah
um
and uh I'm looking for the hot dogs and
I'm trying to find the wieners or
whatever the wieners are right here
um
turn the [__] camera around
what I'm off camera oh I get weird okay
so I'm like am I going crazy can you
please help me Papa because sometimes
you're looking in a rush that it could
be right in front of your face but then
you don't see it yeah he looked can't
find it couldn't find it at all and
we're looking all over the [__] house
I'm like what the [__] did I do with it
and he's checking in the freezer inside
the garage
I'm like what the [__] so I start
digging through the trash because I'm
throwing around because I was like you
know sometimes I'm really absent-minded
I actually throw things away and I'm
like maybe you did too okay so I'm
digging through the dirt sure enough I
threw away the bacon and I was like I'm
gonna wrap it in bacon
and we're gonna use that as an
ingredient you threw it away yeah I
think he threw that away too I don't
know oh I'm a mess I'm sorry I need help
see that's why
I know you're just laying and floating
on top of the bed
did he just fall asleep on me
I think he just fell asleep on me
all right guys so this is what I was
talking about in terms of the view of
the strip except it's from the backyard
I'm in the front yard because I just uh
walked the dogs right now but check it
out
isn't that beautiful
so it's so cool that um Ace the designer
had like
such attention to detail that he was
scoping out every square inch of the
backyard and he was able to like like
see that oh wow we could see the strip
from your backyard too
so he wanted to make sure that like we
maximized and utilize as much as we
could and bring in the surrounding City
and area into the backyard which is
freaking amazing so those are our two
biggest life updates is one of the
capture it and not only to share with
you but to keep as memories for
ourselves
and uh I'm gonna go to sleep good night